[Music]
hey guys it's joanna here a lot of you
have been requesting for a fitness
supplement guide video here it is this
video is in collaboration with ierb and
i'll be sharing with you the top five
beginner's guide to fitness supplements
for female if you have not heard of iev
it is a global leader in bringing the
best overall value in natural products
to their customers all over the world i
herbs offer a selection of over 30 000
natural products from 1 200 brand names
they are very committed to providing
quality assurance for their products and
ship directly from their climate
controlled warehouses hence i've only
shop for my health supplements from
iherb plus they offer free or discounted
shipping for over 150 countries all
across the world i got mine shipped all
the way to malaysia in less than one
week
and it was so convenient so do you take
supplements if so how have they helped
you let me know in the comments below
first of all you have to understand that
supplements will never replace proper
nutrition but they can help you hit your
fitness goals faster supplements
complement our diet and help cover
nutrition gaps ensuring that our body
gets what it needs for pig performance
no matter what your fitness goals are
whether it's to lose weight to build
muscles or just tone up the right
supplements can help you to improve your
health performance and also physique but
of course you should always know what
you're eating so that it will benefit
your body don't just eat anything if you
don't understand it so i hope this video
will make it less confusing for you and
that you will know how to start adding
the right supplements into your diet to
help you with your performance let's
talk about the first supplement protein
when you think of those guys with big
muscles we often associate them with
protein they must be eating a lot of
protein or they must be taking protein
supplements you're not entirely wrong
protein is basically the building block
for muscle it helps to repair and build
tissue and muscle the best protein
source is to consume whole foods such as
meat fish eggs tempeh beans nuts and
seeds everybody's protein needs differ
based on how active they are if you are
active you will need more protein hence
consuming protein shake can help to feed
your muscles but don't worry you will
not be big or bulky otherwise all the
guys in the gym will be super buff and
fit there are many different types of
protein supplements out there and it can
get really confusing for beginners let's
understand the two most popular ones
whey and casein protein these two milk
protein are excellent sources of all the
essential amino acids whey is a fast
digesting protein whereas casein is a
slow digesting protein whey protein
takes only 20 minutes to be digested
absorbed into the blood and fills your
muscles very quickly it is perfect to be
taken before
during and after your workout to feel
and feed your muscles but since the
benefits are short-lived you should
still consume a whole meal 20 to 60
minutes after consuming a post-workout
whey protein shake on the other hand
casein protein takes longer for your
body to fully digest casein actually
clogs inside your stomach it forms
globus of protein in there and this
slows down the digestion rate slow
digestion can be a negative thing before
or after training when you're trying to
get amino acids into the system quickly
but it benefits when it comes to holding
off hunger and this can help with fat
loss casein is best used before fasting
such as before bedtime because the slow
release of amino acids promote fullness
so if this is too confusing for you to
keep it simple some people including
myself like to pair whey and casing
together post workout the idea is that
you get both rapid and sustained amino
acids this way so my favorite is the
milk protein isolate by california gold
nutrition spot which contains both
casein and whey protein and when i buy
my supplement i would want to make sure
that each serving contains at least 20
to 25 grams of protein and this is ultra
low lactose which is perfect for me so i
will consume one serving immediately
after my workout to fill my muscles now
if you're a vegan or if you're lactose
intolerant you can always opt for
plant-based protein supplement which is
usually made from legumes
seeds vegetables and fruits they often
contain slightly less protein compared
to dairy protein however they are high
in fiber and cholesterol free personally
i like this brand by organic protein
because each serving contains 20 grams
of protein which is quite high and 7
grams of fiber let's move on to the
second essential supplement fish oil
fish oils are rich in two essential
omega-3 fatty acids epa and dha omega-3
fatty acids are vital in maintaining a
healthy heart and brain it has also been
proven to reduce inflammation keep the
joints healthy and help to maintain
flexibility which can also help to
reduce injury when exercising it is also
known to increase the body's fat burning
ability so whether or not you exercise
regularly fish oil should be the most
basic supplement to add into your diet
for a healthy adult it is recommended
that we take approximately a daily total
of 500 milligrams of epa and dha
unfortunately most of us do not get
enough omega-3s in our diet hence fish
oil supplement can be a huge help what i
have here is omega 800 by california
goal nutrition because this is a highly
concentrated fish oil supplement
containing 840 milligrams of omega-3
fatty acids per soft gel i will only
need to consume one daily together with
my meal they are better absorbed when
taken with food next check out this
super cute bcaa product by fit miss and
this is strawberry and margarita
flavored so what is bcaa bcaa stands for
branched chain amino acids isoleucine
leucine and valine being the three most
vital nutritionally bcaa can be consumed
through a range of protein-rich foods
like chicken fish meat eggs nuts lentils
and some beans our body is unable to
make them so they must be ingested
either through food or supplements so
when taken during training bcaa gives
you the extra search of energy it helps
to prolong the length of your workout
improves recovery and reduce muscle
fatigue which means you will be able to
train more frequently they are also
known as a muscle builder to maximize
muscle growth reduce cortisol and
increase levels of insulin the anabolic
hormone that is critical to replenish
your muscle tissue with nutrition after
workouts the optimum time to take bcaa
is before and or post-workout you can
add this into your protein shake so
start off by taking about two to three
grams per dose and slowly increase the
dosage to five grams depending on your
workout frequency as well as intensity
this has 5.3 grams per scoop the fourth
supplement i would recommend is creatine
if your training focuses on weight
lifting then creatine should be added
into the list because this can help to
improve overall muscle mass and
definition creatine's most basic
function is to help muscles create fast
energy during exercise it is also known
to promote significantly greater gains
in strength and also high intensity
based performance which means you will
be able to lift heavier and add more
wraps however a big side effect of
creatine for women is bloating unlike
when you're menstruating the water
weight will be in your muscles it may
put you off but once you stop taking
creatine the extra water weight will
drop within one or two weeks if your
training focuses on cardio then this is
not a requirement creatine is simply an
add-on for the benefits of extra
strength and muscle tone take three to
five grams 30 minutes before training
and another three to five grams
immediately after training again this
can be added into your protein shake the
truth is with our lifestyle nowadays it
is not always easy to get all the
necessary vitamins in our body every
single day so the last on my list is
multivitamin think of multivitamins like
your body's insurance which helps to
fill in the nutritional gap in your diet
vitamins and minerals are extremely
important for us to have the highest
quality of life it is an important
supplement not just for females but for
everybody whether or not you're on a
fitness journey saying that however you
should not just rely on multivitamins to
support your health and think that this
is good enough you should still be
consuming whole foods rich in nutrients
to support your overall health so what i
have here is a complete female
multivitamin which contains 23 essential
vitamins and minerals to help my body
perform optimally so i will consume two
tablets daily with my food so ladies
these are my top 5 fitness supplements
which i will recommend for you to start
adding into your diet to support you
through your fitness journey what other
supplements do you take let me know in
the comments below you can get all these
products on ierb ierbs mobile app and
website made it super easy to find
place and track your orders they provide
24 7 customer support in 10 languages
ieve is also always offering amazing new
promotions and discounts every single
week so be sure to check out my
description box for links to all these
products mentioned and you will also get
a discount off your eye herb order do
you take fitness supplements to enhance
your workout if so what is your favorite
let me know in the comments below
be sure to also like this video share
this video on and subscribe to my
youtube channel for a lot more fitness
tips nutritional videos workout videos
and also healthy recipes all the best